Oftentimes in research, we're interested
in making a change in the world and
then measuring the effect
that that change had.
For example,
we might want to give students a tool
that we believe will help them learn,
and then measure how well that
tool actually helped them learn.
But sometimes we're not ready to
actually make a change in the world yet.
Sometimes we just want to understand
the world a little bit better.
We just want to understand
the nature of reality, and
that can then inform some
tools we design later on.
Survey research is one
way of doing this.
In survey research we're not actually
making a change to our participants.
We're just asking them to report on
their opinions, their perspectives,
their experiences.
And using the results of those surveys,
we then construct an understanding of
whatever population we're investigating.
Survey research can be
very complicated though.
It's very difficult to
design a good survey.
It's difficult to know how to draw
a representative sample out of
a population of people.
You might not even know
what those words mean yet.
So in this lesson we're going
to talk about these things.
We'll talk about designing good surveys,
and making sure that the results you get
from those surveys are actually valid
and generalizable to that population.